so Ted Cruz was was questioning Sally
Yates and by the way at this hearing it
was regarding the Muslim ban and of
course her going against the executive
order so this is important because kind
of like we did with with gorsek and they
on the Left said ah can you believe look
at Al Franken own gorsek otherwise
report with us we wanted to wait for
this to happen and then right away I'm
seeing all over the leftist websites
right Ted Cruz gets crushed by by Sally
a stick Cruz gets humiliated watch him
get absolutely beaten down on every
single leftist web site so we always
want to be fair with you and I don't
think it's it's right to just show the
highlights that where we think Ted Cruz
performed best just as we did was Neil
gorsek we took what they showed as their
team members they're a team's best plays
so let's show you what the left it did
Ted Cruz really get crushed
well let's provide more context not less
let's start it off are you familiar with
8 USC Section 1182 not off the top of my
head no well it is the binding statutory
authority for the executive order that
you refused to implement and that led to
your termination so it certainly is
irrelevant and not a terribly obscure
statute okay so that would include it
did proceed the exact clip that is
making the rounds on the left to cite so
this is Ted Cruz's question and Sally
AIT's his response that is being praised
as an absolute crushing defeat for Ted
Cruz
so this is the actual clip let's let's
play this so we can talk about it here
by this express text of the statute it
says quote whenever the president finds
that the entry of any alien or of any
class of aliens into the United States
would be detrimental to the interests of
the United States he may by Proclamation
and for such a period as he shall deem
necessary suspend the entry of all
aliens or any class of aliens as
immigrants or non-immigrants or impose
on the entry of aliens any restrictions
he may deem appropriate would you agree
that that is broad statutory
authorization I would and I am familiar
with that and I'm also now she
familiar no person shall receive
preference or be discriminated against
an issuance of a visa because of race
nationality or place of birth that's
imported after the statute that you just
quoted and that's been part of the
discussion with the courts with respect
to the IMA is whether this more specific
statute
Trump's the first one that you just
described the my concern was not an ia
concern here it rather was a
constitutional concern okay listen you
watch that first off again I watched it
I said hmm I don't see this as a
crushing defeat I mean you know the
Sierra Club Ted Cruz that was crushing
that was really in here I watched that
to get my jollies off gorsek Frank yeah
that was that had Frank and thought he
could burn bacon volley back over in
this case it seemed it seems like two
smart people he asked a valid question
she gave an answer which is a valid
answer depending on sort of the premise
of your argument and we'll get to why I
don't think it's a particularly valid
answer but this is the clip this is the
clip making all the rounds and the
leftist websites so let's provide more
context and show you exactly what occurs
after this clip after the ownage there's
no doubt the arguments you laid out or
arguments that we can expect litigants
to bring partisan litigate grids who
disagree with the policy decision of the
president a lawyer Hartman of Justice
issued an official legal decision a
determination by the office of legal
counsel that the executive order and
I'll quote from the opinion stating from
staying to actual law with respect
quotes to precedent important to note
that's a determination from OLC on
January 27th that it was legal three
days later you determined using your own
words that although LLC had had opined
on legality it had not addressed whether
it was quote wise or pre-empting her
argument that's very smart with legal
sector directive senator said that I was
not convinced it was lawful I also made
the point that the office of OLC looks
purely at the face of the document and
again makes a determination as to
whether there is some set of
circumstances under there
her answer here for more contest would
be lawful
they importantly do not look outside the
face of the document and in this
particular instance particularly where
we were talking about a fundamental
issue of religious freedom okay all
right all right okay listen you can go
watch the full clip this cuz it we
wanted to show as much context as
possible I encourage you to go watch the
full clip and make your own judgments
first off let me tell you I don't think
anyone really got owned there I watched
this and I thought these are two sharp
people from different sides of the coin
having an intellectual argument and I
thought it was a pretty good match of
wits even though I would agree with Ted
Cruz more now if you think that she
owned him
when you take the entire context it's
because you believe several things first
off okay so this is why I say everyone
has a world you everyone has a prism
through which they see the world we
don't need to back away from it say well
I'm not an ideologue those people are
too ideologue so we need to understand
the ideology of both people because that
matters here and whether you like it or
not that applies to to the courts
unfortunately we have activist judges so
the ideology needs to be applied you
need to understand how you how you
certain issues first off her argument is
predicated on the idea that liberals
care about religious freedom then her
arguments predicate on the idea that the
constitutional rights apply American
constitutional rights apply to non
citizens not only to non citizens but
not only like green card holders or
temporary workers here but to people who
merely want to come here in other words
anyone who says I want to be to America
she believes or at least she's arguing
that they are entitled to constitutional
rights I don't believe that's the case
and finally she makes the argument that
relate fundamental religious freedoms so
let's assume that okay this is a
religious freedom issue let's assume
that non American citizens people just
wanting to come here have constitutional
rights let's go with that she said this
is based solely on nationality or birth
the executive order that's her
justification for going against it but
that's not true this is not just based
on nationality or birth this is based on
a national security risk a country or a
list of countries here six seven seven
countries I believe now from which they
work talking about war-torn lands where
people are burned alive and they're kind
of notorious for not integrating in
Western society it's not because you
were born in Syria it's because Syria is
a crapple where people are burned alive
and people with lips are being thrown
off rooftops we the question comes do we
have is it a national security issue for
us to say you know what people are
coming from countries where they haven't
gotten it right they have yet to get the
correct answer on the quiz and if you if
you think that that's not a national
security risk then you also have to
believe that these people anyone any Tom
Dick and Harry you says they want to
come to America are entitled to
constitutional rights and religious
liberty by the way this idea it imagine
this if someone came from a country
saying alright I want to become an
American citizen okay great by the way I
practice religion that has me kill
people every Friday night
wait it's not the religion it's the
fundamental actions that have been
carried out in your country and the
policies that have been determined by
your religion and where your allegiance
is I think there's a discussion to be
had there but again you can only believe
it's an ownage took plate you can only
believe that took place here if you're
looking purely from your ideology and
you're taking everything if you're
watching a short clip like HuffPo would
show you the clip from the full show
Daily Show at ladder with credit com /
mug club or it's available exclusively
69 dollars a year that's less than $6 a
month less than two expensive cups of
coffee or you can feed an African child
but just buy coffee or join the mug club
Daily Show ladder with credit.com slash
mug Club see you there don't feed
children